بدايه دعنا نبدا بهذه التصريحات التي ادلى
بها رئيس الوزراء الهندي
في خطاب افتتاح اجتماع وزراء خارجيه
مجموعات دول مجموعه العيش في نيودلهي
اليوم
مودي قال ان الحكومه العالميه فاشله في
مواجهه التحديات اكثر الحاحا في العالم
معترفا ضمنيا بالانقسامات العميقه بسبب
الحرب في اوكرانيا بدايه استاذ لو تحدثنا
عن الموقف الهندي من ملف الحربه في
اوكرانيا
نعم كان الموقف الهندي واضحا في هذه
القضيه بالذات منذ بدايه الحرب بان تبحث
عن الحل السلمي وانهاء الحربي فورا واننا
نعيش في عصر ليس عصر الحروب وبالتالي هذا
انعكس ايضا في خطاب الرئيس الوزراء وفي
ايضا كلمه وزير الخارجيه وفي خلال مؤتمره
الصحفي اليوم الذي اختتم قبل قليل اكد فيه
ايضا ان الخلافات عميقه بين الدول حول
قضيه اوكرانيا بشكل خاص لكن تم مناقشه
العديد من القضايا الاخرى التي تهم
المجتمع الدولي
طيب وزير الخارجيه الروسيه قلم من جهته
اليوم ان مجموعه العشرين لم تصدر بيانا
مشتركا في ختام هذا الاجتماع الوزاري وبان
الهند ستصدر
بدلا من ذلك ملخصا ملقيا باللوم على الغرب
يعني هل هذه النتيجه ان صح التعبير كانت
متوقعه
طبعا كانت متوقعه لان اولا ما حدث في
مؤتمر الوزراء الماليه قبل اسبوع للدول
المجموعه ذاتها في بنغلا كان ايضا فشلوا
في التوصل الى بيان مشترك وكذلك الامر في
هذه الاجتماعات التي اختتمت اليوم دليل
على ان الاطراف تتنازع فيما بينها وكل طرف
متمسك بموقفه وبالتالي تصريحات تصب في هذا
الاطار وصدر قبل قليل ايضا بيانا من
الحكومه الهنديه تؤكد فيه على انتهاء هذه
الاجتماعات التي استمرت لمده يومين
والحديث عن جميع القضايا بما فيها قضيه
اوكرانيا وان الخلافات كما قال وزير
الخارجيه كانت عميقه بين الاطراف الدول
الاعضاء
بشؤون الاسيويه اشكرك كنت معنا مباشره من
نيود